i watched travis scott on ballers the
guy keeps his eyes closed the whole time
looks down like this the whole time
yeah strange strange cat you that's
another good documentary
you're a little older for it but you'd
appreciate it what well they just they
show his come up they show him at this
music festival in his hometown of
houston
tell me about him what makes him so good
good rapper or just
i don't know he's that good of a rapper
he's just like he's he's definitely
unique
a personality he just makes no not he's
not a person you know what he just makes
good music that's really yeah it's it's
great he's not a person that's a big
deal he's
just a good musician i think he
writes and then produces his own stuff
and he got really
he got really hot on soundcloud and then
this this this
netflix uh uh luke says look mama can
fly
they show him when he's like first
getting started and they show him at
like this thing in houston
and you know like it's travis scott and
there's
seven people in the crowd nobody's
listening to him and then they
three years later and dude it's he's in
an arena
and like travis scott in the crowd was
[ __ ] wow
it's really cool damn really really cool
brian i don't know if you would know
this but that is kylie jenner's baby
daddy
i do know that yeah it sounds like him
and kind of get a divorce huh
oh yeah i heard she met with divorce uh
attorneys i wonder what that looks like
because he's worth a billion she's not
struggling so it's like
it's just cuss you the kids i feel like
they probably have a prenup yeah
well customers some kids if he's got
mental illness that's a very
dicey you know that's tough
it's not going to be easy on him you
worry about a guy kanye you really do
like you you worry about what he might
do i i don't include
the the videos and stuff i don't look at
any of it i don't it's so sad i don't
see any of it
so kim posted this i think yesterday
very recently she's
she's saying that she's she wants
empathy from people because he it does
deal with bipolar disorder
so it's tough for them and the family
like so it's tough that
everyone's kind of looking at kanye as
this crazy guy but she's really dealing
with
wow yeah so she has as many as you know
kanye has bipolar disorder which he was
diagnosed a few years ago
and he was on medications decided to get
off it because he feels less creative on
it
so he says anyone who has this or has a
loved one in their life who does knows
how incredibly complicated and painful
it is to understand i've never spoken
publicly about how this has affected us
at home because i'm very protective of
our children kanye's right to privacy
when it comes to his health
but today i feel like i should comment
on it because of the stigma
misconceptions about mental health those
that understand mental illness or even
compulsive behavior know that the family
is powerless
uh unless the member is a minor people
who are
unaware or far removed from this
experience can be judgmental and not
understand that the individual
themselves have to engage in the process
of getting help no matter
how hard family and friends try correct
i understand kanye is subject to
christendom because he's a public figure
and his actions
at times can cause strong opinion
emotions he's a brilliant but
complicated person who on top of
the pressure of being an artist like a
dumbass that run for president
uh uh who experienced the painful loss
of his mother a steal with the pressure
annihilation
isolation is heightened by his bipolar
those who are close to county know his
heart and understand his word sometimes
do not align with his intentions
living bipolar disorder does not
diminish or invalidate his dreams
and his creative ideas no matter how big
or unattainable they may feel
that is part of his genius and we have
all what she's dealing with
yes good for her well dude imagine
that's the father of your
children she's going through a lot she
suffers with language she has
psarias is really bad she's dealing with
this there's a lot of stuff it's not
like how much money you have you know
dealing with stuff but apparently she's
not a
[ __ ] load to get in the innocent
exonerated she seems like a pretty good
person
yeah not that new uh do you want to take
me through your
baggy blue socks that don't match with
anything these are my boosts
and uh what i'll do is i'll recycle
socks so i wear them one day
and i go warm for a couple hours i'm
gonna wear them again i do the same yeah
i do that i do that with all my stuff i
don't like to waste water
i do the same uh yeah my buddy one time
it bothers me i think about it once a
week and i don't know why
this is 15 years ago he's a little bit
of a spoiled nancy
he's been he was coddled as a kid he put
on some [ __ ] jeans
okay he went downstairs his wife said it
might be hot for those jeans and he said
you're probably right took them off put
them in the [ __ ]
laundry hamper well that's laziness i
went
well that's just lazy those aren't dirty
and he goes man i know but
that's lazy that's lazy done that
bothered me i've done that before all
right you guys
i'll just throw them on the ground get
them out right now fold them well i'll
just throw mine on the ground
yeah phone i'm gonna throw them in the
ground because i'll wear them again yeah
i'll put them in a laundry hamper it
bothers me i get it though it's lazy
maybe just want to put on there because
you didn't feel like rehanging it you
know bought two blazers this weekend
bought two blazers oh yeah the guys were
gonna wear genius let me ask you this i
wear them why buy blazers you have
nowhere to go
because and b where the [ __ ] are you
going that
people are fitting you for because i'm a
high testosterone 53 year old
and a man of my age should wear a blazer
and a convertible
corvette nope convertible corvette
yellow right in case i get into a
situation why did you buy blazers where
are you gonna wear those pop off
wherever i want when it's chilly and
when it's not chilly
i'm going to be a blazer guy where'd you
go to buy them
uh i i went to rag and bone
could good i'll fabric and they had a
sale they opened couldn't resist
they were open yeah and they had a sale
well i mean [ __ ] yeah no [ __ ] you know
what i mean everywhere's on sale yeah so
i got some good
threads for very cheap so you could wear
it at your house
i couldn't i couldn't resist well once
they come up with a vaccine i'll be out
on the town yeah you look fresh papa i
want to look fresh
like i sit back and i worry not because
people
who maybe are are feeling oppressed
feeling
hurt feel excitement in bringing someone
else down and feeling
like they have an active part in it
that's why they're doing it makes sense
i don't like it but i i get that what i
don't like
and what i think is even more concerning
is that this overall
feeling of everyone getting excited
at the misfortune of others it's really
sad and i don't think it's just social
media i think that
the real me like the the actual
mainstream media plays a bigger role
um well here's one a quick example like
i was watching um i never watched any of
gordon ramsay's tv
until the um the lockdown i just started
watching
some of gordon ramsay's shows and
there's a hell's kitchen or some other
show where he goes in and he talks [ __ ]
to people who don't run a restaurant
right i just started watching them too
for whatever reason
and so they have this episode where this
guy's an
[ __ ] he yells he's petulant he
doesn't want to hear what gordon ramsay
has to say he's lazy he runs
and the editing and the and the show
creates this idea through
through through the way the way they
created the episode made you just hate
this guy
and made you want to hear gordon ramsay
lay into him yep
and i could feel myself going like yeah
get him gordon he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
well because i'm watching them you know
now
years later they have the like extras on
the streaming services
i'm watching it he starts interviewing
him at the beginning
of before they start even going into the
restaurant and finding all these flaws
and he said yeah i uh my father passed
away very young and
he he was our only parent my mom died
too and so my brother raised me and he
got in the restaurant industry and he
was my hero and i modeled everything
wow everything around how my brother did
it and frankly
he was the he was the dad i didn't know
how to run a business
but i just want to be just like my
brother my brother died eight years ago
of like some free cancer and so now i'm
left here and i don't really know how to
run this restaurant
and you're like oh wow yeah oh that
that's but yeah but but fox or whatever
production company said
we can't go that route no one's going to
want to watch we got to create this idea
so that we stand up and go go gordon
[ __ ] this guy up
and i'm like this is what we need to get
away from you're talking about that
happening to gordon that happened the
guy
that happened this is and and but yet if
you watch the episode you didn't
happen to like him for going to tandem
if my daughter didn't start screaming
for some reason and i didn't lost sight
of it
and then this thing kept going and i
watched the [ __ ] extras which i never
would have watched
i would have had no idea and yet the
episode created this idea
for the sake of ratings for the sake of
getting people to watch the show
over and over again that like no this
man bad this man
terrible we should cheer on gordon
getting upset and stuff
someone else fauci had the worst first
pitch of all time do we have that
too
uh i was reading this article with fauci
you know he said he's he's
when he was going through the first
crisis stuff you get hate mail
because i've never got hate my like i
have for this
you know my kids and my wife have been
you know we've had to have stricter
security
say people are mad at me because i'm
trying to you know i'm just doing my
best what i know
you know being safe and people are mad i
think i'm you know trying to go against
trump and shut down
the economy they're pointing the finger
at me i'm just giving you my
recommendations you guys do what you
want but don't point like what do you
want me to do man yeah i'm a disease
expert right i'm telling you what i know
right you know
i want it's a bummer let me see dr
powshy here
oh oh 50 cents is way worse
yeah 57 people just hate pouchy food 50s
was way worse
it's tough if you've never done it man
well you do it before
you do oh yeah that's not your first
[ __ ] but then it's like you know your
nerves
and stuff i would love to tell you i
would love to try it
you know the the joke here a lot of
people are saying obviously like he was
social distancing the ball from
home plate all right we've talked about
this before but i used to work for cnn
and hln uh a while back
and there was this instance where i was
on i'm not like a confrontational guy
but one time i was on
this is live tv and there's this girl
there she's a reporter from
you know bullshit.com uh somewhere up in
in the bay area
and there's this instance where this man
um
it appeared to be homeless who knows but
he was he was clearly not right
he was walking through the streets of
san francisco with like a
machete okay okay obviously cops are
called can't have that cops call
um it's a group of cops uh a black
gentleman by the way the the machete guy
um shop's gone a lot of damage emission
a machete very very unfortunate
yeah very unforgiving ask ms-13 they can
you can do some serious damage with a
machete yeah um cops come try to gather
around him and then they uh initially
like three or four cops
a couple of them black corral the guy
and
happen to maybe you know throw him down
or whatever they can do to get cuffs on
him and take away the machine
very very appropriate he's lucky that
you're just shocked so we're having a
skating shot if i'm a cop i might have
to shoot you
totally agree i'm thinking i don't know
[ __ ] about policing but i'm thinking in
my head i was like man that was a pretty
measured way to handle it they didn't
[ __ ] blast the guy he has a
deadly weapon was he naked too no no but
he was he was usually
screaming and talking himself and um
this
reporter is saying like and and here we
see yet again another
um example of white supremacy so i
i absolutely lose my cool and i start
screaming at her and i i mean like
vayne's coming on my neck on live
television type move
and it goes on the crowd's cheering
everyone's yelling and everything
and i sit back and we go to commercial
break and i'm like [ __ ]
i'm like i [ __ ] up i really [ __ ] up
and this this girl had to be like 21 or
something and i'm dum-dum
shark right maybe i i maybe intellectual
stuff aside i'm like
i shouldn't have done that and i and i'm
like man i'm probably gonna get it
talking to you from the producers i'm
like
this is not good so we go to commercial
break i go over and i'm like i'm sorry i
don't i totally don't agree with you but
i shouldn't have done that that was
wrong and an apology she's like it's
okay i thank you for saying that did you
get in her face
no we were we were ten years apart but
i'm literally like
that's fine are you [ __ ] considering
all the real white supremacy in the
world and
think about what emmett till's family
has to think about that when you're
calling policemen doing their work
good you know right you know yeah and i
i still think i'm right but
my point being is like totally lost mike
was a man i'm gonna hit him yeah
i get off with the show ends uh i get
back to the green room to take off my
makeup and
the executive producer comes in and i'm
thinking like oh here he goes
he goes dude oh that's what i'm talking
about
okay and i'm like what he's like that's
television here we go you know
it is so two months later uh we have
uh it was like a explosion right when
caitlyn
tran uh transferred over into what bruce
wayne bruce went to caitlin
so there was a lot of transaction a lot
we had a a um
a trans activist and then also uh some
religious
figure i don't know if he's a priest or
a pastor but he was a man of the cloth
and he was on there and he uh
disagreed with me and disagreed with
this activist but at the same time was
incredibly measured very kind and was
everyone was kind of talking he
disagreed that
he should be able to well just talking
trans that it wasn't
mentally illness it's not a mental he
was going the
the kind of traditional religious route
that a man is a man a woman is a woman
you can't change that blah blah blah
okay
i was having some disagreement with him
this lady was having some disagreement
with him
but everything was very civil and
actually very and he was really
likable and nice i'm like
oh that was that was really great i hope
more people saw that because you could
see that you could have disagreements
and
it would be said well i get off i go to
take out my makeup [ __ ] executive
producer comes in he's like
we can't we can't be having you back if
that's all you got
i go dude he's like come on babe we're
we're in the ratings business yeah we
need to fight and this is kind of neat
so uh younger kids are taking advantage
of the whole mask thing so they're
dressing up as old people to buy alcohol
smart
some of them are pretty good and they're
getting away with it huh
yep and this is i think a dude put a wig
on a wig you know those things you put
on top of a scarf on the top it makes
you look like you're an older woman too
so that's a fun one i'm sure and uh
let's go over here
yeah look at your story's like who's
trying to get hey guys he gives a [ __ ]
you see my back ripple and i pull myself
up like a
champ like a chimp 30 times while
talking to you
why wouldn't i give that to you as it's
a gift it's a gift
it's a gift